a report emerged on sunday that the
saints are talking to free agent
quarterback jameis winston about doing a
contract and now that the window is
closed on the compensatory draft pick
formula they are free to get that done
with no impact whatsoever on how many
compensatory draft picks the saints
would get next year how many the
buccaneers would get part of the
strategic
effort to delay the signing in order to
influence that process next year but
assistant gm jeff ireland in new orleans
saints was on matt mosley's radio show
on
monday chris and he acknowledged that
they are talking to jameis winston and
he made it clear that it's in jameis
winston's best interest to join the
saints said ireland brees is an
incredible leader he's an incredible
study of the game how he breaks down his
opponents then you throw in offensive
coordinator pete carmichael quarterbacks
coach joe lombardi and coach sean payton
on the offensive side of the ball those
creative minds jameis winston
will learn more football in a year
than he has in his lifetime
that may be true
but man that's a slap
at everyone else that ever coached
jameis winston the idea to learn more
from sean payton pete carmichael and joe
lombardi in one year than he's learned
in his entire life take that bruce
arians head coach of the buccaneers take
that dirk cutter offensive coordinator
of the atlanta falcons take that jimbo
fisher who really won't matter to the
sex at this point because he coaches
texas a m but cutter and aryans have to
be a little bit upset about this
assessment don't you think
well i it's certainly they're not going
to read it and go oh how nice of jeff
ireland to say yes you're right i mean
there's no doubt
i'm sure it'll it'll piss them off to a
degree uh i don't think jeff ireland
necessarily meant it that way you know i
know jeff ireland a little bit i think
he was more touting the knowledge of
coaches he has on his own staff and what
they have in new orleans which is
special i mean those names you talked
about there those are guys that we know
are first leading with sean payton who's
in the conversation for one of the best
offensive minds we've seen in the sport
over the last 20 years you know and of
course the people underneath them and
and carmichael and lombardi have been
talked about have been offensive
coordinators quarterback coaches been in
those conversations before too so uh you
know you you can't really deny the
results you know it's a little bit of a
slap in the face to a guy like bruce
arians who's certainly put up some great
offenses and dirk cutter has certainly
earned his way here in the nfl too but
sean payton what new orleans do
they operate on a different level from
the rest of the nfl i don't think
there's any doubt about that you know
them new england there's a few other
offenses out there that yes have their
base scheme but are also just another
level of creativity on a week to week
basis with personnel sets and formations
and new plays and things like that to
where they're a cut above the rest of
the nfl in my opinion the saints that
way that's why i admire sean payton so
much
but here's the thing with jameis winston
right bruce erin specifically came out
of retirement to coach jameis winston
and the buccaneers they had a connection
that went back to like pre-florida state
days he had known winston for years he
was all in on getting the most out of
james winston every coach has that
high level of confidence boarding her on
arrogance bordering on delusion that
they can fix any player that needs to be
fixed and bruce ahrens was going to fix
jameis winston and then by the end of
the year he couldn't wait to get rid of
him chris because he saw that that uh
reduction in his abilities in december
that inability to rise to the occasion
that 30th interception in overtime
against the falcons that sealed their
fate on the season and he was just done
and and
look i i know bruce arians even though
he's a two-time coach of the year has
never won a super bowl but sean payton
has
um i don't know is sean payton that much
better of a coach that he's going to
iron out the rough spots with jameis
winston when aryans just couldn't
well i it's not this is it's a little
bit of a different
you know a a way to attack phil
philosophical wise i guess that's the
way i'm trying to say it here more than
anything you know hey we all know you
say it we have fun all the time bruce
arians is no risk it no biscuit jameis
winston that's never been an issue for
him i mean he's always risking it for an
extra biscuit we
that's what worries us so i don't know
if the combination
you know
two negatives don't always equal a
positive right that's where i think
maybe you could make an argument to now
where you go with sean payton where
their offense is about efficiency and he
is the master of getting
wide receivers wide open you know five
and six yards down the field which also
makes a quarterback be more comfortable
with decision making through the game
because you know jameis winston at times
too he played on a team that was not
always great and he had to force the
issue and goes damn there hasn't been
somebody open in the last seven times
i've dropped back to pass let me try to
make a play and jump start our offense
and that has led to bad things he won't
have to do that if he plays with the new
orleans saints sean payton to be like
hey relax i'm the king of getting the
guys wide open for six yard gains you
don't have to do risk it no biscuit you
can sit here and just listen to what i
say and i'll find you some easy
completions and then those big pass
plays will kind of just come to you
throughout the flow of the game because
everybody worries about those other
things so that's where i think it's a
good mesh mike
and and look i love teddy bridgewater
but
i would have never expected him to go
5-0 last year with drew brees injured
never ever
right sean payton found a way to make it
happen now teddy bridgewater did it but
sean payton helped him do it
no doubt so i agree with you the idea of
building confidence you talk about this
all the time easy completions early in a
game just to get the nerves out of it to
build up that confidence to get a guy
behind he can make the big throws down
the field in a big spot
that's part of the philosophy and that's
part of the challenge of designing a
game plan it's not just attacking the
defense
it's putting together plays that help
your players get into the zone get into
the rhythm a hundred percent
necessary to win and uh you know i don't
want drew brees to get injured but if
winston does sign with the saints and i
was told last night it's definitely
going to happen
i i kind of want to see him play i kind
of want to see what he can do
not not coming in off the bench i want
to see him start a game at some point
for the saints this year a game that
counts a game that matters and again the
only way that's going to happen is if
drew brees gets injured so i'm not
wishing that on him i mean i guess brees
could just fall off a cliff this year
from the standpoint of his skill set and
get benched although i don't think
that's going to happen either i just
want to see what winston can do with
sean payton as the head coach it's
nothing about brees it's all about i
want to see what winston can do
i'm with you mike i mean yeah i hear you
and yeah i don't want anything happen to
drew brees i want to see a great last
year i want to see the saints make a run
i just got too much respect for all of
them in that organization
uh where i enjoyed their style of play
but yes i mean jameis winston in an
offense like that you know there's you
you think there's potential for special
i don't think there's any doubt about
that and mike i think you're you know
again what you said about early
completions it is real that's a real it
it filters throughout the whole football
team i mean how many times i've seen
great offenses whether it's kyle
shanahan or tom brady in new england or
sean payton and drew brees the first
drive of the game we can go back and
watch games of the new england patriots
and i'll go yeah you know the the tv
announcers will go to break and go
brady's on fire seven for eight after
the first drive and you sit there and
really watch what he did you go he threw
six screen passes a slant route and the
coaching staff just did a great job of
game planning but yet it gives everybody
that confidence the quarterback the
offense the offensive players look at
the stats on the big screen board they
go man our quarterback's on fire look at
him even though he might not have thrown
a real pass yet to that point of the
game so that is a very real aspect of
building the confidence of the offense
and the quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports